how dare we allow our society to be
dictated by people who occupy the
minority on either sides like how dare
we and how do we come together in
civilized
fashion brother and sister arm and arm
to say I may disagree but I want to hold
space and I love you and I care and I
want you to do the same for me the world
is complicated and we don't make
progress by bullying other people into
believing that they're bigots we make
progress by finding out what people
think and why they think it
yeah and and assessing that against what
we think and why we think that and where
the hell are the idealists where are the
leaders we need in the times not to take
advantage of our divisions but to bring
us together and it sounds corny and
idealistic and I think that's the point
I think we need more corny idealism and
uh we need it more than
ever